>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> Stephanie Marcus: I'm
Steph Marcus from the Science,
Technology and Business
division,
and I want to welcome you
to the second lecture
of our 2018 series.
Our next one will be May
15, and that's going to be
on water security,
using satellites
to monitor water
around the Earth.
Mars, it's always
popular, and it seems
like just recently we had a talk
on Maven, another Mars mission
that was called Case of the
Missing Martian Atmosphere,
but that was in 2014, and our
speaker is, was, on that team,
and he's also going to be
on the upcoming Mars 2020
team if we get the money.
So, right now he's going
to, he's all involved
with the Rover Curiosity,
and today we're going to hear
about the five years
of information
that we've got from Curiosity.
Our speaker is Dr.
Scott Guzewich.
>> Dr. Scott Guzewich:
Thank you.
>> Stephanie Marcus: I bet
none of you guessed how
to say his name, but I'm
glad I learned it's Guzewich,
and he is, he was a web
officer in the Air Force,
so a little bit different
background
from some of our speakers.
He got his degree in meteorology
from Penn State and an MBA
from Cameron University, and
then finally his PhD in Earth
and Planetary Sciences
from Johns Hopkins.
So, let's get started
and hear about Curiosity.
Thank you.
>> Dr. Scott Guzewich:
All right, thanks Steph.
>> Stephanie Marcus:
You're welcome.
>> Dr. Scott Guzewich: All
right, so hello everyone.
I'd like to talk to you
about the last five years
that we've explored
Mars with Curiosity.
I'm a member the Mars
Science Lab science team.
I've been a team member
since just after landing,
and today we'll talk about
swimming in Martian lakes.
So, what I want to start with a
little bit here is we're going
to go in the way back machine,
and we're going to kind of talk
about our history of Mars
over the last century
and why we are exploring
Mars today with Curiosity
and how much we progressed
over the last hundred years.
I mean literally in
my grandparents' time,
this was the vision
of Mars that we had.
And it's pretty remarkable
when you think that just
within a generation or two we've
gone from having a spacecraft
on Mars, multiple
spacecrafts on Mars
at the same time exploring
Mars, to having people
like Percival Lowell
peak through telescopes
and then hand draw pictures
of what they think they
saw on the surface.
And the sort of work by people
like Percival Lowell really
captured the imagination
because he imagined sort
of with a mistranslation
from an earlier Italian
astronomer, Schiaparelli,
that there were these
canals on Mars,
that the Martians were living
on a dying world, bringing water
from their receding polar caps
down to their drying farms
at low latitudes, and that this
was sort of the vision of Mars
that then captured the
public imagination.
Field science, fiction,
things like Orson Wells'
famous radio broadcast,
and this was the vision of Mars
that most of the public had.
And so, you know, we kind
of imagined not only
was Earth populated,
but of course Mars
must be populated.
Venus perhaps too.
This was the place that
we thought we came from.
And really only a couple
decades after this, you know,
not long after Percival Lowell
died we went from this vision
of Mars to having a space
program where we could think
about actually sending a
space craft, as primitive
as it may have been, to Mars to
see what Mars was like truly,
truly there, and the planet.
And so early here in the
Space Age in the early '60's,
it was actually the Soviet
Union that was trying to do most
of the Mars exploration
and unfortunately failing
miserably for the most part.
They sent, actually
the Soviet Union
and Russia has never had
a successful Mars mission.
But they sent a number
of Mars missions here,
and they either all blew
up on the launch pad,
a couple actually made it
into space and then failed
at some point during
their transit to Mars.
Of course in the U.S. we also
had some failures as well.
And note though here that a
lot of these in the early days
of the space program
were launched in pairs.
They built things redundantly.
They had two of the same
space craft because they knew,
a lot of their rockets blew up,
a lot of their space
crafts failed.
And so, you know, the Soviet
Union would launch things
in pairs.
We would launch things
in pairs as well.
So Mariner 3 here was a launch
failure, but thankfully,
the next one website not.
And that was Mariner 4.
So Mariner 4 was the
first space craft
to actually make it
all the way to Mars.
This was the fly-by mission.
So we had sort of a philosophy
in planetary exploration
where we fly, fly by, we orbit,
we land, and then we rove.
So fly-by means take the space
craft shooting past the planet
and hopefully taking as many
pictures or pieces of data
as we can as we go by.
And early days here in the
early '60's, this was 1965,
Mariner 4 flew by and took
20 pictures, 20 pictures.
We take hundreds with
Curiosity every single day.
Twenty pictures was
the whole breadth
of our exploration
from Mariner 9.
And, you know, take a
look at this image here.
This is one of the images.
Now we knew what the
moon looked like, right.
We've been looking at the
moon now with space craft
and telescopes at
this point in 1965.
We knew the moon was a dead
place, but we still had
that hope that maybe Mars
was at least something
like what Lowell thought it was.
Maybe there was, okay, maybe
there were not civilizations,
but there was always maybe
plants or there's microbes
or there's something
there that's not the moon.
And so Mariner 4
flew by and saw this,
and I've asked elementary
school kids, you know,
what do you think this picture
is, and they say the moon,
and it was like well exactly,
and that's what everybody
thought.
It was like, oh, we actually
found Mars was just a big giant
red version of the moon.
And so without waiting
for anymore data,
the New York Times confidently
declared Mars is dead.
That's it folks.
It's over.
Mars is dead, we don't
need to bother anymore.
President Johnson was so
glad that he was not going
to be invaded by Martins
because he was terrified
from the 1938 Orson
Wells broadcast.
So he was like, okay, good.
We're not going to be
invaded by Martians.
We only have to worry
about those Soviets.
But then Carl Sagan here
pointed out, now 20 pictures
at 1 kilometer resolution,
so most of your good
weather satellite data is 1
kilometer resolution.
So can you see any people
or even cities really
at 1 kilometer resolution?
Not so much, you know.
You can see plants, because we
know what the color change is
from fall to spring
and that sort of thing,
but you don't see any animals,
and so Carl Sagan quipped here,
if there were kilometer-long
elephants covering the surface
of Mars, we wouldn't
have seen them.
But actually this sort
of disappointing result actually
did result in a reduction
of funding for March
exploration in the late '60's,
but not enough hopefully,
thankfully, to kill the program
because we actually
sent Mariner 9.
And what Mariner 9
did was actually went
into orbit around Mars.
And so this was key because
instead of just flying by
and shooting a bunch of
pictures as fast as possible
and then shooting off into
space never to be heard from,
Mariner 9 went into orbit.
And it went into orbit at
a very particular time,
where it was lucky
it went into orbit,
because if it had just flown by,
all we would have seen
was this giant dust storm,
which is what actually I study.
But there was this huge
global dust storm on Mars
when Mariner 9 arrived in 1969.
And these dust storms
occur periodically on Mars
where the whole planet is
shrouded in this dense haze
of dust, and you cannot
see the surface at all.
And so imagine if it had
just been shooting by.
We would have just seen
these murky photographs
with no surface features
whatsoever.
But luckily it went into
orbit and so it could wait
until the dust began to settle
and the dust dissipated,
and as the dust was beginning
to dissipate, we saw these,
four actually, one's
off the screen here,
but these four giant little
spots on the surface here,
and what these are, these are
volcanos, and these volcanos are
so large that they
actually essentially stick
out of the atmosphere
into space.
The one volcano that's off
screen here is three times the
height of Mount Everest.
And this mountain essentially
sticks above, sorry,
sticks above the surface
of the planet so far
that the atmosphere is
essentially all below the top
of the mountain.
And so the volcano sticked
above this layer of dust,
and so we could see these.
And then as the dust began
to settle, we finally began
to see Mars as a real place.
And we saw amazing
features like this here.
This is an ancient river
valley called Nirigal Vallis
that looks anything like a river
valley here on Earth, the Nile,
the Amazon, the Mississippi,
whatever the case.
All these branching tributaries
and things like that,
and we finally realized,
Mars is not the Moon.
It's not Earth, but
it's not the Moon.
It's a distinct place
all to itself.
And soon after, in the
mid-'70's we send Viking,
and Viking not only orbited
but landed two space craft.
This is surface frost
here on a cold morning,
just like we have
here in DC or Maryland
on a cold winter morning.
We get frost on the
ground that then evaporates
or sublimes during
the afternoon.
Same thing here on Mars
where Viking landed.
And we finally saw Mars is
a real place unto itself.
It's a unique planet
with unique properties
and maybe an amazing history
that we don't quite
understand yet.
So Viking went primarily
to find life.
So we knew by Mariner
9 here, okay,
we're not finding
any civilizations.
We're not finding any giant
forests or anything like that,
but there's still maybe
good reason to think
that there's microbes
in the surface.
We know there's water
in the polar caps.
There's water in the atmosphere.
You know, maybe there's liquid
water sort of percolating
in the soil, and maybe
there's still microbes.
So that's where Viking
was sent to explore.
And Viking landed and had
very specific measurements
that they were taking
to test for life.
And the most famous of these
or perhaps the most infamous
was called the Labeled
Release Experiment.
So what this did is it
scooped up some soil.
It put it in a little chamber,
and of course microbes
need to eat, right.
So they fed the microbes with
a very specific type of food
and water that was marked with
a certain radioactive isotope.
So presumably, the microbes
would eat this radioactive food,
and then they would respire and
kind of breathe this back off
in there, and then that
respiration would be tested for.
And they did several of these.
And so here's a control
experiment, right.
Nothing happening.
You know, didn't feed anything
to the soil, nothing happens.
You feed something
to the soil and boom,
you get this huge
response, which would suggest
that there are tons of living
microbes in the Martian soil.
And, of course, this was
understandably exciting.
You know, this is a, this is
exactly the sort of result
that people would have expected.
But thankfully we didn't
just sent the Labeled
Release experiment.
There were other tests that we
did to the soil to see, okay,
there should be other
things, other properties
that living things
would have in the soil.
And so one of those was
called a mass spectrometer,
and that's designed to basically
test what the soil's made of.
And so every living thing on
Earth has organic molecules,
carbon-bearing molecules
in it, right.
And so you should have tons
of carbon-bearing molecules.
If the life is like Earth,
you should have all this
carbon-bearing material
in the Martian soil.
And not one organic molecule
was detected, not one.
And so there was this
puzzling contradiction here.
You have this seemingly
very positive experiment,
but then you have every other
sign, not just this one,
but every other test saying
that there's no life at all,
and not even like a hint of it.
There is nothing there.
So you have a very
positive and then
like three very negative
results.
And this was very puzzling
for obvious reasons,
and actually the, Gill Liven,
the PI here still insists
that the Labeled Release
Experiment found life.
Still insists because he
believes there are some other
problems with the
other experiments.
But his opinion is
certainly in the minority.
And we have a pretty
good understanding
of why these experiments
gave the results they did now
with more knowledge.
But you can imagine here, so
we went there looking for life,
and the general consensus
was we didn't find it.
You know, Mars truly is dead.
And that was pretty
disappointing because, you know,
Mars was sort of the last
hope in the solar system
at that time, or so we thought.
And so we kind of went to this
long pause, essentially 20 years
where we didn't send
a mission to Mars,
and there's obviously
some other reasons why
that probably happened, but
certainly scientifically was
because Viking was sort of
disappointing in that way as far
as searching for life.
There were certainly
lots of exciting things
about maybe Mars a long
time ago, but nothing today.
And so the only space craft
launched over a 20-year period,
from 1975 to 1996, was
Mars Observer in 1993.
This was a very capable
mission, and it got literally
within 3 days of Mars and then,
uh oh, it did not turn out well.
And the general consensus
is there was a fuel line
that somehow got ruptured
and basically shot it off
in an opposite direction.
It lost radio contact
with Earth and never
to be heard from again.
Now this was a pretty
big mission,
so that was disappointing,
obviously.
This was the first Mars
mission in a long time,
and during a period where
NASA was not sending a lot
of planetary missions.
I mean nowadays we're sending
usually one or two per year,
knock on wood, and we're not
doing that as much 20 years ago.
So that was pretty
disappointing,
but soon afterwards, we had
a very exciting moment occur,
and this was a very
formative moment in my life,
and if any of you were kind
of alive and paying attention
to the news in 1996,
particularly in the summer
of 1996, you would
have remembered this,
because this was on
all the news channels.
And I was at the beach at
this time on a vacation
with my family, and I was
glued to the TV screen.
I could not pull myself
away from this news,
which was that this rock,
a Martian meteorite,
had evidence of life in it.
And so this rock,
it's called ALH84001.
So this designation is how they
assign names to meteorites,
and it's basically because
this was found in Allen Hills,
Antarctica, in 1984, and it was
the first one of the season.
So every summer in Antarctica,
winter here, we send a team
of scientists down to Antarctica
to collect meteorites.
And so why are meteorites really
easy to find in Antarctica?
Because this is brown,
and Antarctica is white.
All right.
So they stick out.
I guarantee you, there
are meteorites here in DC,
not far away, but I couldn't
find them for you, you know.
They don't look any different
to me than any Earth rock,
but on Antarctica, the only
thing there is meteorites.
And the way the glaciers
flows actually,
so these meteorites sometimes
can actually get incorporated
into the ice, get buried
by long distant, you know,
hundreds of feet
down into the ice.
And then as the glaciers flows
up against these
mountain ranges,
they sort of get kind
of pulled back up.
And there are fields
essentially full
of meteorites just sitting
there where these glaciers sort
of kind of let them
deposit as the ice sort
of evaporates way
against these hills.
And so there are
certain places here.
One of my colleagues just got
back from this a few months ago.
Teams go down to these certain
places and collect meteorites,
and the reason, when
this was first found,
it was actually thought
to be a lunar meteorite.
And the reason we know
this came from Mars is
because we sent Viking there,
and we know what Viking
found Mars to be made of.
And we said, hey, okay, this
is what Mars is made of.
This is Mars.
And we've only found a few
of these Martian meteorites.
There's literally
like a couple dozen,
and some are actually kind of
probably from the same rock.
What unique about ALH84001
is it's very, very old.
It's like three and a half
or more billion years old,
and we can do that by various
tests to see what the ages are,
the various materials in there,
that this is a very ancient rock
that was formed at a time when
probably Mars looked a lot more
like Earth, and so that
alone made it very exciting.
But then they started
digging into it more,
and they found certain
chemistry that on Earth is,
at the time we thought,
seemingly only produced
by biology.
And don't ask me
what those things are
because I'm not a biologist,
but there were certain things
in there that are only
produced by living things.
And then of course what got
all the press was this picture.
This is an electron
microscope picture
of what looks all the world
like some sort of worm fossil,
the difference of course
being that this is tinier
than any microbe on Earth.
This is nanometers
long, extremely tiny,
but it sure looks like
a worm to me, right.
So this is the fossil that
we found in the Martian rock.
And of course this was
basically all over the news.
President Clinton made a
statement there at the time,
and this was really
what drove me to want
to study Mars because,
you know, this just kind
of captured my imagination.
Instead of being out there on
the beach enjoying my vacation,
I was watching TV in the room,
all about a Martian meteorite.
And so this really kickstarted
a new era of Mars exploration,
because really about
the same time in 1996,
we launched the little
plucky Sojourner rover here,
which landed on July 4,
1997, and just for a sense
of scale here, Sojourner is
about the size of
a small microwave.
So, and then the Spirit
and Opportunity rovers,
this is Spirit as
seen from orbit.
Spirit and Opportunity sort of,
you know, go up to about here,
and you know, maybe cover
sort of this whole area
over on speaker's lectern,
and then Curiosity is
essentially a mini Cooper.
So that's you sense of
scale where, you know,
kind of moving up there.
And what really changed then
in 1996 was we had a
Mars exploration program.
We didn't have these
one-off missions.
You know, Viking
was two missions,
but it was sort of a one-off.
And then we went 20 years,
and then we had Mars Observer,
which was a one-off, and it
failed, so nothing happened.
And then we said, hey, you know,
we're going to have a
whole program that's going
to follow the water, that
was the catch phrase,
and we're going to learn
about the history of Mars,
and we're going to understand
where the water went,
did Mars have life long ago.
And this started all kind
of with the little
Sojourner rover there,
and then we sent orbiters,
the orbiter looking
down here on Spirit from above.
So at the same time, we
finally had things active
on the surface and
active in orbit.
And that's really key
because you get the sense
of perspective that's
totally unique
that you can't get
from either place.
Of course, if you're
on the ground,
you're in one little
spot, right.
I mean how much could
DC tell you about Earth?
I mean honestly, if you
took away all the buildings
and everything, I'm
not a geologist that,
well I don't know much, but
how much could DC tell you
about Earth?
You know, could it
tell you about deserts?
No. Could it tell
you about oceans?
No. Could it tell you
about the polar caps?
No. You know, one
little place on Mars,
how much can it tell
you about the planet?
But then you get that in situ
knowledge that then you can use
from orbit to kind of
extrapolate to the planet,
and you get a much
broader perspective,
and that's what having a
program really offered us.
So that kind of went
for a few years,
and now we got to about 2003.
And so this is what
we knew by that point.
We knew Mars once had
flowing liquid water.
This is an image here of
an ancient river delta,
and it looks all the world like
what you would see if you looked
at a satellite image of
the Mississippi flowing
out into the Gulf of Mexico.
You see these sort of
branching patterns.
In southern Louisiana you
get these branching canals
and networks of things
as it flows out and sort
of new channels form
constantly, and it moves around.
And that's exactly what
you get here on Mars,
but of course it's all dried up.
There's nothing there now.
But long ago, there was
something there, and we can tell
by just the shape of this delta,
the way these different channels
kind of cut over each other
and are deposited on
top of each other.
We know that this actually
lasted for a long time.
This was not just a
one-off giant flood
that then evaporated immediately
and was gone within
a few months.
This took time.
This took a lot of
time, you know, decades,
millennia, maybe even more.
We knew Mars once
had a magnetic field.
A magnetic field on Earth
protects us from the solar wind.
So the solar wind is
constantly trying to kind
of strip away our atmosphere.
And because the Earth is
bigger, that helps too,
but we have an active magnetic
field that kind of pushes all
of that charged particles
away from Earth.
And if any of you were here for
the Maven talk a few years ago,
that's what happened
to Mars basically.
The magnetic field went away,
and the whole atmosphere
was basically stripped off
into space, just pulled
away over billions
and billions of years.
And it's still happening today.
Mars is still losing
atmosphere today.
And so we knew Mars once had
a much thicker atmosphere.
We didn't know how thick, but
we knew it was thick enough
to allow liquid water
to flow on the surface.
And you need to have some
amount of sort of heft
to the atmosphere to
allow that to happen.
It can't happen today.
And so this was 2003, and so
what kind of became was the idea
for the Curiosity rover, which
would have been a step up.
At the time, it was going
to be a more incremental step
then what it ended up turning
out to be, but an
incremental step
above Spirit and Opportunity.
Because what we wanted to answer
was how long did the liquid
water last?
Was this really like a flash in
the pan, you know, decade-type,
decades, you know,
intermittent-type thing,
or was this a long-term thing
where life would have had
time to evolve perhaps.
How long did that
thicker atmosphere last?
These kind of go hand in hand.
And even if liquid
water was there and even
if the atmosphere was there, was
the environment truly habitable?
You know, was this some sort
of like acidic, boiling mess
that only like the
most extreme lifeforms
on Earth can survive in.
Or was this something much
more temperate, you know,
kind of what we hope, which
was much more temperate clement
environment where all
manner of life could live,
at least as we understand
it here on Earth.
And then was the
chemistry right?
Did we have the different
ingredients that life needs?
Life needs a whole host
of different chemical
compounds to live.
It's not just carbon.
It's not just water.
There's phosphorous.
There's nitrogen.
There's any number of
different things that life needs
to have the different pathways
form chemically, to have sources
of energy to live on, and
so was the chemistry right?
And so we said, okay, so this is
what the next mission is going
to address.
This is what Curiosity
will address.
It wasn't called
Curiosity at the time.
It was called the Mars Science
laboratory, which it still is.
But that was what this
mission would accomplish.
And so as we packed on all these
instruments or what we wanted
to put them, and we said,
wow, this thing's going
to be pretty darn big.
And unfortunately when
it's pretty darn big,
we can't land it the same way
that we landed things before.
So before with Spirit,
Opportunity, and Sojourner,
we had these giant airbags.
Has anything ever
seen videos of how,
sort of artist conception
of how these landed?
It's pretty wild, right.
I mean, they're all kind of
wrapped up in these airbags,
and then the parachute
drops, is descending
through the atmosphere and
essentially just drops it off.
And it just bounces and rolls
and eventually settles down,
and the airbag is
deflated in this thing,
the clamshell is open, and then
the rover just sort of stands
up in the middle of
this and drives off.
Well, Curiosity is
way too darn big.
There's no way for
Curiosity to fit in airbags
that could survive
that sort of thing.
It's just too much force
that would hit on the ground.
And so we need to come up with a
whole new way to land Curiosity.
And what the engineers at JPL
in their infinite wisdom came
up with is called Sky Crane.
And the first time I saw this,
I said this is the craziest
thing I've seen in my life.
There's no way.
There's no way this
is going to work.
And I was telling Steph I've
now seen crazier things,
which makes me even
more concerned.
But, and the JPL
engineers would kind
of famously say this was the
least crazy thing they came
up with.
This was the least crazy thing.
And so we'll show you a
video of how this works here,
but basically there is no
packaging for curiosity.
Curiosity came down
wheels down, and that's it.
And it was ready to go.
So, okay, we had a mission.
We knew what we wanted
to do with it.
We had a new way
to land it on Mars,
and then the question
is where do you put?
And this is a question
that we're actually deciding
right now for the next mission.
So Curiosity's twin sister,
or almost twin sister,
they're fraternal twins, is
going to be launching in 2020,
and we're now down to three
candidate landing sites
for the Mars 2020 mission, and
it'll be decided here at the end
of the year where of
those three it will go.
And so similarly there was
a long list of candidates
for Curiosity, and it's not
just science that drives us,
there's engineer
requirements too.
So Mars' southern hemisphere
is a lot higher altitude
than the northern hemisphere.
And there's just not enough
air to slow us down enough.
You need more air
just to slow us
down as we're entering
the atmosphere.
So we can't land in the
southern hemisphere,
at least too far
south, and we can't land
in the high mountains,
and we don't want to land
in the really crazy places
like valleys that have lots
of rock walls and
dangerous things around them,
so we need somewhere
that's safe to land
at a low enough elevation but
also scientifically interesting.
And when you kind of
black out the parts
of the planet that's
not safe to land on,
you're not left with that much.
I mean you're kind of left
in this narrow band roughly near
the equator, kind of minus five
or ten degrees south to
like 15 or 20 degrees north
and at elevations below
like a kilometer or two kind
of below Martian sea level.
And so in that list, eventually
Gale Crater kind of rose
to the top, and the reason is,
is because it had all these
different chemical compounds,
clay compounds, sulfates,
things like that,
that on Earth indicate
the presence of water
and different types of
water and different ways
that water has interacted
with the rock.
There was evidence that there
was this river valley that sort
of flowed into Gale Crater
and maybe left some sort
of delta here or fan, and
somehow there were sort
of different signs that
water had played a big role
in Gale crater.
And so this is why Gale
was eventually selected.
And this is an artist's
conception
of maybe what Gale looked
like billions of years ago,
and this is sort of an
Earth-like, or a picture
of Earth here at a
high mountain lake
of maybe what you can
kind of use as an analogy.
So probably kind of
salt, maybe was it salty?
It's possible.
But, you know, you
have not a lot
of living things around it here.
There actually are some plants
there if you look closely,
but this is sort of what maybe
Gale looked like, you know,
three and a half billion
years ago or more.
And so we had a place to
land, we had a mission,
and then I want to show
you this little video here,
which I think really kind of
shows well the whole evolution
of the mission and the
work that went into it.
I mean this was,
so this was 2003
that the mission was first
conceived of, and now it's 2018,
and we only landed in 2012, so
there's a huge amount of time
that it takes to
build these missions,
to develop the science case
for them, and then to go ahead
and actually get them to Mars.
Oops, let's go back.
[ Music ]
>> That great things take
many people working together
to make them happen is one
of the fantastic things
of human existence.
>> Now that we've driven the
rover, we've moved it's arms,
we put it all through
it's paces, but it's been
in a thermal vacuum
chamber and kept very cold.
Parts of it have
been in a centrifuge.
We've done drop tests,
pull tests, drive tests,
load tests, stress tests.
It's just an amazing amount
of testing this vehicle
has gone through.
We've tried every way
of operating the vehicle
using the software.
Literally thousands
and thousands
of hours of software testing.
It's been just an amazing
several years really
of constant testing and
development, finding problems,
fixing those problems, and
going on to the next problem.
I think she's ready to go.
[music]
>> LC, this is the
LD on channel one.
LC, you have permission
to launch.
>> Roger, proceeding
with the count.
>> T minus ten, nine, eight--
>> Seven, six, five, four--
>> Three, two--
>> One.
[ Explosion ]
>> Am I confident
that she's going to go
and she's going to
be successful?
Absolutely.
That this is going to
go, and she'll be good.
[ Music ]
>> We should have the parachute
deploy around Mach 1.7.
>> Parachute is deployed.
>> We are decelerating.
>> [Inaudible] have separated
and we're on the ground.
>> Standing by for
[inaudible] separation.
>> We are in flight.
We're at an altitude of 1
kilometer and descending,
[inaudible] back for sky crane.
Sky crane is started.
[ Background Noise ]
Touchdown confirmed.
Proceed.
[ Applause and Cheering ]
>> Let's see where
Curiosity will take us.
[ Applause and Cheering ]
>> What a fantastic
demonstration of what our nation
and our agency can do.
I could only think of the
words of Teddy Roosevelt
as I was sitting there.
It is far better to dare mighty
things even though we might fail
than to stay in the twilight
that knows neither
victory nor defeat,
and the team brought
us victory today.
>> Today, right now, the
wheels of Curiosity have begun
to blaze the trail for
human footprints on Mars.
>> This is an amazing
achievement.
>> Well today on Mars
history was made on Earth.
The successful landing
of Curiosity marks what
is really an unprecedented
technological tour de force.
It will stand as
an American point
of pride far into the future.
>> We've got a long mission
ahead of us, and because of that
and the capabilities of this
rover, we have this possibility
for just monumental
science accomplishment.
>> Within two months, the team
found an ancient riverbed,
evidence of flowing water.
We--
>> Dr. Scott Guzewich:
I'll give you guys the end
of the story so far.
But you saw during the video
there, this is a picture,
so Curiosity has a camera
underneath it called the Mars
Descent Imager or MARDI, and
so MARDI took a video basically
as soon as the heat
shield came off,
and here it is floating
down, never to be seen again,
it took a video all the
way down to landing.
And it's pretty remarkable.
You can look it up on YouTube.
But here's another image here.
So this is the rocket boosters
there, you saw on the side,
sort of shooting off, and
it kicked away all the dust
from the surface right in
the spot that the rover was
about to touch down on,
and so you saw all this
dust being kicked away,
and then this was one of the
first pictures that came back.
This is, we have four
cameras kind of pointing
to the front called
hazard cameras looking
for rocks basically.
We don't want to drive
over anything big and sharp
and pointy, and this is
one of those cameras.
So we're looking out,
seeing the shadow.
It landed kind of towards
sunset, and here's the center
of the Gale grater,
this giant mountain
which we called Mount Sharp,
and sort of where we were
headed from that beginning.
So it was a pretty, a pretty
poignant image that, you know,
this is sort of the journey
ahead as soon as we touch down.
And I was an active
fan here watching
from home before I
was a team member.
And if you look real closely,
this shirt is not brand new.
So this was 2012.
So Curiosity was supposed to
launch originally in 2009,
and there was technical
problems like happens in space,
because space is hard.
And so I bought this
shirt like back in 2008,
so this was already
like four years old
when we finally touched down,
but it worked out thankfully,
and sky crane worked,
and hopefully it'll work a few
more times because they're going
to use it again in 2020 and
even want to use it again
if we ever land something
on Jupiter's moon Europa.
And so here we are, and again
this is sort of why it's
so important to have a
Mars exploration program,
because this is a camera
looking down, the HiRISE camera
on the Mars Reconnaissance
Orbiter, which has been there
for 12 years already
and is working great,
and looking down here and
seeing the rover tracks,
so here's all the dust that
got kicked away from the spot.
You can see like the
burn marks basically
from the rocket engines
on the surface,
and then you can see this little
faint track that went over here
to this area called
Yellowknife Bay.
And if you recall from earlier
on, you know, we wanted to get
up the mountain because that's
where all these clays and things
like that, these
materials that showed
that water had once
been present,
were all up high
on the mountain.
That's a long way
from where we landed,
and we couldn't land
on the mountain.
You know, it was
just not safe enough.
So we landed in this flat
spot, sort of in the middle
of the crater, and we
always knew we'd have
to drive a pretty far distance.
But we went here just a
few weeks after landing
over towards this area
called Yellowknife Bay,
and this was believed to be
maybe just a, sort of a edge
of where that possible
river delta kind of flowed
out into Gale crater
at some point.
And I wasn't even on
the team at this point.
I joined like very soon
afterwards, but I don't think
that anyone truly expected
to find what we found
in Yellowknife Bay.
So one of the most,
the first things
that we found were
these types of rocks.
These are called conglomerates,
and you can see here there's
all these little imbedded rocks
in the bigger rock.
There's little chunks rounded,
and particularly
they're all rounded.
So you know, if you go
in a stream bed here
on Earth they're
all kind of rounded
because the water has flowed,
they've kicked up and knocked
against each other, and all the
jagged edges have been smoothed
down over time.
And a long time.
It doesn't happen
in a day or two.
This happens over years.
And these rocks are all smooth,
and then they're all kind
of congealed together into one
giant rock, and again that's
by the action of water.
And we get the same
thing here on Earth.
I mean if you handed me this
and you dusted off all
the Martian red dust
and you handed me
this from Earth,
I couldn't tell them
apart, that's for sure,
but these are the same sort
of, same sort of processes
that are occurring
on Earth and Mars.
You have a stream bed
that's flowing over,
rounding these pebbles
out, and then kind
of congealing them
together into one rock.
And again, this is because
this area, and so this is
where we landed, and we
drove just over here and was
on the very edge of this
what's called alluvial fan,
so this kind of delta,
this river valley here
called Peace Valle,
it flowed out into this,
presumably this lake or the end
of the river, maybe through
the, just kind of dried up,
we didn't know at the time, but
it reached all the way down here
that the stream bed or what
was left of the stream,
and this was not just, this
was not just, you know,
sort of inches deep water.
This must have been a few
feet deep at the very least
to create that sort of flow.
You can't just have it from
a little bit of a trickle.
You need to have a true stream
or river to create that sort
of motion, to round
those pebbles out.
So similarly, we found
these very fine layers here.
You can see they just kind of
peel away almost like, you know,
[inaudible] dough from like a
Baclava or something, right.
They're just very fine layered
materials, and you can see here,
there's, you know,
very small scale,
these are like millimeters
thick sometimes or centimeters
at most, and they're all kind
of peeled away and then kind
of got jumbled around over time.
But again, this shows
that you have sediment.
So again, you have
suspended in a river,
you have little tiny particles,
right, sand particles,
dust particles, or whatever,
suspended in the flow,
and over time they
sort of settle out.
And so, again, like
the Mississippi River,
you have all these deep
layers of very fine sediments
that have been deposited over
long, long periods of time.
Kind of muck and mire
that has then kind
of solidified into rock.
And again here on Earth, this
is sort of an ancient lake bed
in Scotland, 400
million years old,
and you see the same
sort of thing.
Now these have been tilted up
by other geological activity
over time, but you see
this very fine layering
in this material here in
Scotland, and it's the same sort
of thing we saw here on Mars.
So, again, another piece
of evidence that hey
that this was something
that happened
over long periods of time.
This was not a flash in the pan.
This was not days,
weeks, months.
This was years and
maybe even millennia.
So we were the first time,
Curiosity has a drill on it,
and this is the first time
we've really drilled into Mars
and found that Mars has this
very peculiar color here.
Mars is not red, it's gray.
Much more Earth-like, lunar-like
gray here beneath this red
Martian dust.
And now that we've drilled
a couple dozen times,
there's actually different
colors of different rocks.
We found like purplish-colored
rocks,
these more gray-colored rocks.
Some have kind of a
greenish tinge to them even.
And we've drilled in
here and then been able
to sample these inside
Curiosity's laboratory.
One of the handouts out there
is one of the instruments,
the big instrument on Curiosity
called SAM, which was built
at Goddard, and I'll
show a slide here.
The next slide is
actually about SAM.
But we take this material
here, we scoop it up,
and we deliver it in very small
doses into the instruments
that are inside Curiosity's
body,
and then we can really tell
what these are made of.
So we did that, we dropped
pieces of it into it,
and the point is
here that there's
that water came out of this.
There was oxygen.
There was sulfur-bearing
compounds,
and the different temperatures
that these come off of are sort
of indicative of
what this is made of,
and we can tell what
the mineralogy is
of these materials.
And what I particularly want
to highlight is are this
material called carbonates.
So carbonates are extremely
common here on Earth.
The Cliffs of Dover, these
cliffs of Normandy here.
You have hundreds of
meters or hundreds
of feet thick carbonates.
And there's nothing magical
about how these are formed.
Now they can be formed by living
things, by little creatures
in the ocean have like carbonate
shells and they kind of fall
out into the bottom of
the ocean, and over time,
like the whole bottom of the
ocean is essentially nothing
but tiny little fossils of
microbial life from the ocean,
but they can be formed without
biological activity as well.
All you need is water
and then carbon dioxide
in the atmosphere, and the
chemical reaction occurs
by itself, and it turns to rock
and turns to carbonate rock.
And so long ago in Mars
exploration we knew, okay,
if Mars had a thick atmosphere,
presumably it was
carbon dioxide.
Venus' atmosphere is
all carbon dioxide.
Earth's early atmosphere
had a lot of carbon dioxide.
Mars' early atmosphere probably
had a lot of carbon dioxide,
and it would have needed to
if it was going to be as warm
as it would have been
necessary to have liquid water.
So there should be just a
absolute ton of carbonate rock
on Mars because presumably Mars,
all that atmosphere got locked
into carbonate rock
at some point.
And we've looked
and we've looked
and we've looked.
And there is not giant cliffs
of carbonate rock on Mars,
and if they're there, they're
hiding really, really well,
because we've looked everywhere.
And so we wanted to know, like,
okay, there's little bits of it,
we found little bits, so
where did the rest of it go?
I mean if there was this
huge thick atmosphere,
as thick as Earth's atmosphere
today, and it's all gone
and it's not buried in
the rocks, you know,
the only place it really
could have gone is space.
And this is actually an image
from kind of a graphic figure
from the Maven mission,
that mission that's studying
the upper atmosphere of Mars
and how it's losing
atmosphere today,
and so but using the combined
work of Maven studying
up at the top of the atmosphere
and then Curiosity right there
at the surface, we can
measure the atmosphere
and tell how much
of it has been lost.
And one way we do this was
with a particular type
of gas called argon.
So we have argon
in our atmosphere.
It's the third-most abundant
gas in our atmosphere.
There's your trivia
fact for today.
It's also the third
most abundant gas
in Mars' atmosphere.
And just like a lot
of compounds,
there's a heavy version,
and there's a light version.
So have you ever heard of
like carbon 13 and carbon 12?
Same sort of thing.
So there's heavy argon,
and there's light argon.
And if you have all that sort
of atmosphere lost to space,
usually the heavy stuff is left
behind preferentially, right.
It's just harder for the
heavy stuff to get sent away,
the light stuff gets
sent away first.
And so that ratio,
whatever ratio of heavy
to light was there
originally, that guy kind
of changed over time, right.
And it's changed on Earth.
It's changed on Jupiter.
It's changed everywhere,
and on Mars it's changed
in a very particular
way that shows
that it probably lost almost
all of its atmosphere to space.
And because of having Maven
there and having Curiosity
at the same time, we
were able to tell that.
Similarly for water.
Water has a heavy version
and a light version.
Hydrogen does.
And so we can tell that that
ratio right now is really high,
a lot higher than Earth.
It's way up here.
It's about six times'
sea water here on Earth.
But by measuring with Curiosity,
by digging into that soil
and then measuring, because the
soil was created a long time
ago, billions of years, we note
that that ratio was much
lower billions of years ago.
So it's changed over time,
and it's changed because over
that history from when that
rock was created until today,
Mars has lost an absolute
ton of it's atmosphere.
And so three billion
years ago a lot
of the atmosphere
was still there,
and a lot of the water was
still there, and between now
and then, it's all gone away.
So in Yellowknife Bay here,
we had a really remarkable
find so early in mission.
I think that was the key here.
Three months after the mission
was sent, we found that Mars
at ancient times was
capable of supporting life,
and not exotic life, like very
common life, life that we'd have
in drinking water here today.
Anything that's in here
could have survived
in Gale crater three and
a half billion years ago.
There was the water.
There was the chemical
ingredients
that we know life needs.
That was key.
And we've had even
sources of energy.
So different microbes
need different sources
of energy to live on.
It just doesn't need
to be photosynthesis
or eating other animals.
There's different
things that life can do,
and that source of
energy was there.
So the key takeaway here
is that at the same time
that we know life was forming
on Earth, so we know that three
and a half billion years ago
there was microbes living
on Earth, in environments
very similar to this,
where you had chemical
ingredients necessary,
you had sunlight,
you had open water,
and we know that life was
forming on Earth at that time,
three and a half billion years
ago, and at the exact same time,
Mars had that same sort of
environment, and we don't know
if there was anything living
there, but it could have.
You could have transported
any of the microbes
that were forming on
Earth at that time to Mars
and they would have
been perfectly happy.
You could have transported a
trout from today to Mars three
and a half billion years ago,
and the trout would be
perfectly happy swimming
around because the water
not only was pH neutral.
It was clear.
It was clean.
It had all the different
chemical things that life needs.
Low salinity, it wasn't
particularly salty.
So we found, we kind of
hit pay dirt very soon
after the mission landed.
But again, we didn't
sort of stop there
because the whole point
of the mission was always
to climb this mountain and
see all these different layers
of rock that had been deposited
over long, long periods of time.
And so we started driving,
and we've driven a long way.
We've driven 20 kilometers now.
And so here's just sort
of an image here crossing a
little sand dune here called
Dingo Gap.
We drove in amongst
these different,
these different buttes.
So there is the rover
tracks here.
I like seeing these little
sort of circle patterns,
so when the rover turns, it kind
of creates a circle in the dust
because the six wheels together
kind of turn in conjunction.
It's got all-wheel drive,
so they can all turn
at the same time.
And you can see these
little turn marks here
that winds it's way down, and
there it is again from orbit.
And so we found other evidence
that the story of water
in Gale crater was
much more complicated.
It wasn't just a stream
flowing into a lake.
There was probably
different episodes.
So there was long periods of
time where this lake was present
and this river was flowing, and
then probably it would dry out.
And then probably the
lake would come back.
And then other times there
was ground water coming
up from underneath, and so we
found these different layers
of sandstone and other
materials that show
that they were deposited by
water, standing surface water
at different times
in Mars' history.
Similarly here, so you
have these different layers
that are sort of tilting
upward toward the Mount Sharp,
that center of Gale crater.
And so you can imagine here
you have this lake kind
of overflowing here, and
you have rivers flowing
into the lake, and you
have a different sort
of rocks deposited
at different places.
Here you have more
lake-like deposits,
and here you have more
river-like deposits
that are farther
up, up the flow.
And so that sort of combination
of being able to drive across,
driving across all
these different layers,
kind of gives us
that full picture
of how water interacted
on the surface.
And of course the chemistry.
So you see these
little white veins here
that are mixed in the material.
So you have this rock material
and water kind of flows into it
and percolates through,
like a coffee pot,
percolates through these
rocks, and they interact
with the materials and they
leave different minerals.
So on Earth you get these things
all the time, and there's things
like gypsum and other rock
materials that get left behind
as water percolates through
and kind of chemically reacts
with the rocks that are
present in the first place.
And so we saw these all over
the place as we drove past.
Here too, we saw sort of
difference of two layers here.
So we had mudstones down here.
So if you imagine, has
anybody ever swam in lake,
kind of not an ocean but a lake?
Kind of mucky and muddy
on the bottom, right.
Pretty gross if you
actually kind of walk
around for the most part,
but that's because you have all
this different material that's
sitting in the lake and then
kind of settling down over time
and creates this
sort of mucky bottom.
And this is what
mudstone is, basically.
If you then take all that
lake away and let it evaporate
for a couple billion
years, you're kind of left
with this dry, craggily
mudstone.
And up here, you have
sort of sandstone.
So you have sand dunes that
eventually get kind of hardened
into rocks over long
periods of time.
And so you could see here at
some point we were at the bottom
of lake, and then eventually
sand dunes kind of came over top
of it, and then those
hardened and those disappeared,
and then we sort of went through
these different periods of time
where water was interacting
in different ways.
So in that mudstone, you
see this sort of cracking,
and this is exactly
what you get.
If anybody has been to the
desert and seen like a,
right after a rain storm,
you kind of get these little
wet spots that then dry
out really fast, and they kind
of leave these little
cracks in the surface.
That's exactly what this is.
You get these little
cracks in the surface
when the material dries out
after being wet previously.
And so here's sort of a
version of that here on Earth.
You get very wet surface,
and then it starts to dry
out in the sunlight, and you
get all these different little
cracks form over time.
More evidence chemically
that the Mars was habitable
and Mars had water interacting
it was these different veins I
talked about just a minute ago,
and the particular chemistry
in there called boron,
particular element,
again indicates that the way
that the boron is
interacting there in the rock
that these materials were
in place with water flowing,
and there were different
amounts flowing
at different spots
along Gale crater.
So, all right, I've
told you that story.
Now, let me tell you
what I actually do.
So if I've convinced you
that I'm a geologist,
I've done my job, and I've
fooled you all very well.
That's not what I do at all.
This is what I do.
I study the atmosphere
of Mars with Curiosity.
And the atmosphere in Gale
crater is extremely dynamic.
It's really interesting.
These couple of videos
here just sort
of show some of the
things we see.
And this bottom one has
a really funny story.
So dust levels are
extremely common on Mars.
The little whirl winds that
kick up dust that you see here,
even on a windy day sometimes if
you're out in the field or like
on a baseball field sometimes
you see these little dust devils
pick up.
And they don't last very long,
and they, you know, spread dust,
and they have strong winds
and that sort of thing.
Well on Mars they are
all over the place,
and with the Spirit rover
we saw them every single day
just about.
They're extremely common.
We've seen them even from orbit.
They're so tall you can
see them from orbit.
They cast shadows
on the surface,
and they leave little tracks,
dark tracks where they move dust
around on the surface.
And so for the first
couple years of the mission,
we were dedicated to looking
for these dust devils,
and we stared off into the
northern side of the crater,
looking, looking, looking,
all the different time,
saw maybe one, and
it was like really,
you had to really stretch
the heck out of the image
to even convince yourself
there was one there.
And so a couple years later
we said, hey, you know what,
we landed in a place, the
only place on Mars we've seen
that doesn't have dust devils.
And then someone said,
well why don't we look
in the other direction?
And we said, okay, let's
look in the other direction.
And here they are, all over the
place in the other direction.
So all we had to
do was turn around,
then we would have seen them.
But, no, we didn't turn around.
We were dedicated to
looking off to the north.
But here they are,
all over to the south.
And so these dust devils on
Earth, you know, are what?
Maybe like 50 feet high,
something like that.
These can be the size
of like and F5 tornado.
I mean these are big, like
20 kilometers high sometimes.
These are big, massive
giant things.
Now the force of the wind
on Mars is so much less.
It's not like they would, you
know, pick up your house and,
you know, send you off to
Kansas or anything like that
or over to Oz or whatever.
But they're pretty strong,
and they're really important
for how the atmosphere
actually works in cycles.
And so they're just
all over the place now.
We're seeing an absolutely
ton of them.
And actually the season
on Mars right now is
when we start seeing
a lot more of these.
So we've started looking
for these again a lot more
because we just left the
cloudy season on Mars,
and we're entering sort
of the dusty season.
And so these are images
of clouds on Mars,
and these are just like
cirrus clouds here on Earth.
Now if you were standing
in Gale crater looking up,
you probably wouldn't
see these very often
because they're very thin and
they're probably hard to see
with the naked eye, so we
kind of stretch the heck
out of the image here, and you
can see them very clearly kind
of passing overhead.
But they're very wispy, just
like cirrus clouds on Earth.
You see little structures
in them sometimes.
They're pretty exciting to
see, and we again are just,
just left the cloudy season
and now we're entering
the very dusty season.
So we've been on
Mars for five years,
and now we are finally
really climbing the mountain.
So this was actually
an old image.
So we are up right
about here right now.
So you see we've climbed about,
you know, 300 meters or so
of elevation since
we first landed,
and we're finally entering these
different types of rock units
and sort of chose Gale
crater in the first place.
I mean that's why we went
here, and we're finally now,
after five years and 20
kilometers of driving,
finally reaching these places.
And we're up high, and we can
look back out over the crater
and see kind of where we came.
And I thought this image
was just remarkable.
This was not taken too
long ago, because it's
in the clearer season on
Mars when there's less dust
in the atmosphere
because in a couple
of months you wouldn't even
be able to see here the edge
of the crater because it
would just be too dusty.
But you see here, this
is where we landed.
This is Yellowknife Bay
where all that evidence
of water was found,
and we crossed this dune field a
couple years ago, and now we're
up here on this ridge
that's very rich
in a material called hematite,
which again is something
that on Earth is very
commonly in place by water,
and we're finding lots of
evidence of that here as well.
But again, it's a
different story.
The story is much more complex
than what we thought
it was originally.
There was lots of different
ways that water interacted,
lots of different ways that
the environment was habitable
at different times over
the history of Mars
and over a long period
of time in Gale crater.
So this is our route,
and this is as of
about a week ago
or a little more.
So here we are way up
here when we landed.
That's just the distance we
drove to get to Yellowknife Bay
where we found all
this evidence of water.
And we've driven all
the way down here now.
And so here's this ridge
called Vera Rubin Ridge
that we're sitting on now.
And then we're kind
of moving off
into this next area here
probably later this year
over the summer sometime.
And so I'm replaying this
slide here because I want
to point out clays here.
So clays are really what has
been exciting for the geologist
for a long period of
time because clays form
with water present and
they are really good
at preserving ancient
signs of life.
They're really common on Earth,
where if you find fossils
and things like that, clays are
a great place to look for them.
And so we're finally just about
to get into the area of clay.
So this is the clay unit here
that has yet to be named.
We're kind of overlooking
it here, and we're going
to be heading into this
area later this summer.
So the story is certainly
not over,
and I think there's lot more
that we're going to learn here
over the next couple years,
and hopefully we'll
keep driving along,
because there's a lot
more mission to do.
And I encourage you
all to follow along.
This is the Twitter handle.
Every day that we have
operational planning,
someone writes a little
blog about what we do.
I'm one of the people,
about three times a
month I write the blog
about what Curiosity is doing.
And so I encourage you guys to
check that out, and I'd be happy
to take any questions
you might have.
>> Stephanie Marcus:
Thank you very much.
And he will repeat the
questions so we all hear.
>> When you talk about the
dust storms, you know--
>> Dr. Scott Guzewich: Yeah.
>> [Inaudible] the atmosphere
is just two percent of Earth.
>> Dr. Scott Guzewich: Yep.
>> [Inaudible] how
is it possible
that you're lifting anything,
or is that a [inaudible]--
>> Dr. Scott Guzewich: Yeah.
That's a great question.
So the question was, with
the atmosphere being so thin,
how can you have enough force
to lift dust off the surface?
So that's a really good question
because for a long time
people didn't understand.
So we saw like evidence
that dunes were moving,
and we said how are these, how
are dunes moving because we,
just based on physics,
you should know what kind
of force is required
to start a particle
of sand moving along
the surface.
And it seemed like you would
need just insane wind speeds,
like 200-mile-per-hour wind
speeds for that to happen,
which obviously should not
be occurring very often.
And so in a little bit
more sort of refined work
and working a little
bit closely,
it looks like you still
need very strong winds
to get something to start going.
So that first sand
particle to start moving,
you do need something
very strong.
Maybe not 200 miles per hour,
maybe 60, 70 miles per hour,
somewhere in that sort of
range, but once something moves,
then you don't need that sort
of force to continue it to move.
So then you can drop down to
a much more common wind speed
to keep it moving along.
And so the way the
physics works there
on Mars is a little different
than how it works here on Earth,
where you sort of need that
speed to maintain it moving.
But then Mars, that's
an atmosphere that sort
of helps you out a little
bit once it's moving,
because then you
can keep it going
without too much more effort.
And so that's how
we think, you know,
you get a little sand
particle to move.
The sand particle kind
of hits the surface
and it splashes off
little tiny dust particles,
and then those get
lifted into the atmosphere
because they're much
smaller and much lighter,
and then they can just
kind of go forever.
>> So how would you
represent the Mars winds?
Was it something you would feel.
>> Dr. Scott Guzewich:
Oh, right.
So the question is,
would you feel Mars winds
if you were standing
there on the surface.
So if the wind was
strong enough, yes.
So the force is about
a factor of 10 weaker
for the same wind speed.
So if you had a 100 mile per
wind on Mars, it would feel
like a 10 mile per hour
wind on Earth, more or less.
That's the force.
So like the movie The
Martian where, you know,
Matt Damon is lifted off the
surface and a boulder is like,
you know, thrown into him and
the radio tower impales him
or whatever, it's not happening.
I love that movie too, and
my wife was like, you know,
she's like, come on, is
that really how it would be?
And I was like the one
science they got wrong was the
atmospheric science.
But he knew that it was wrong,
he needed a plot device.
He said this in interviews.
And he said that was
better than aliens.
So no, that would
never happen on Mars.
But yes, if you were
standing out there,
like if a dust devil blew over
you, you would feel something.
It wouldn't knock you
off your feet though.
>> And has Curiosity
been hit by a dust devil?
>> Dr. Scott Guzewich:
So the question is,
has Curiosity been
hit by a dust devil?
Yes, it has.
So we have an air pressure
sensor on the rover
so we can see a little
dip in the air pressure
as the dust devil passes over,
and you can also just tell
because the amount of
dust on the surface
of the rover gets
blown off sometimes.
So this was actually really key.
So Spirit and Opportunity were
designed to last for 90 days.
So Opportunity has been
there for 14 years now.
And so that's really good
on your warranty, all right,
and the reason is
because they thought,
well the mission was just
going to die because the amount
of dust would cover
the solar panels,
and eventually you
just wouldn't be able
to generate enough
power to do anything.
And so there's this nice, if
you look at the power output
from the solar panels on
Spirit and Opportunity,
you see this nice, kind of
steady decline, and then boop,
and it bumps up, and it
declines, boop, and it bumps up.
And it sort of reached
the steady state now
that they've been able
to continue to work
with because they constantly
get a dusty devil to pass over
and blow off the solar panels.
Not completely clean, not
brand new from factory clean,
but clean enough
to keep doing work.
>> I was noting that in a lot
of the imagery the sky here is
bluish as opposed to reddish--
>> Dr. Scott Guzewich: Yes.
>> That we found in
the Viking missions.
>> Dr. Scott Guzewich: Yep.
>> Is that [inaudible] or
better imagery or [inaudible].
>> Dr. Scott Guzewich:
So the question is,
why does the atmosphere look
blue in this image, for example.
And so all photography
is fake, and that's why,
because this has all just been
processed in a certain way.
So it's called white balancing
basically where they try
to basically bring out
the different tones
of the rock better because
that's really what they're
looking for, and so they white
balance the image to bring
out the different tones in
the rock more at the expense
of making the atmosphere
look very earth like.
So if you look on one of
the, on these websites and go
into the raw image
files, you can see in some
of the color images the
atmosphere looks very pinkish
and reddish like you'd expect.
But when that happens, you wash
out a lot of the differences
in color in the surface, and so
the geologists run things more
than those atmospheric
scientists, and so they kind
of white balance it to bring out
the contrast in the rocks more.
>> If everything is grayish
below the surface and not
that far, where did
all the red come from?
>> Dr. Scott Guzewich:
Good question.
So the question is, if
below the surface is gray,
where did all the red come from?
And that is a question that
people are still trying
to figure out somewhat.
So the reddish color
is the dust primarily,
which literally covers the
whole planet at some depth,
whether it's just microns
or even meters of dust,
and so the dust has a lot
of iron oxide, so it's rust,
and that's why Mars is
red, because it's rusty,
and so that is still
an ongoing question is,
is the whole planet
basically producing this dust
at all different spots or
are there certain points
that are kind of
preferentially producing it?
And different people
have different feelings
on that topic.
But wherever the dust came
from originally, it has been,
it is covering the globe,
and it constantly cycles
around between the
surface and the atmosphere.
And so the whole planet is
covered in it to some amount.
But below the surface,
yes, there is probably just
as much diversity and color to
the rock that Earth might have,
and so some of it's gray.
Like I said, there's actually
sort of a family portrait
of the different drill holes
that we've done with Curiosity.
You can probably find
this online pretty easily,
and you can see that some
are that very gray color,
like I showed in the
image, and some have a much,
much different color or
even a combination of colors
because the different rock
materials they're drilling
into are unique.
>> Where the jets
blew at the surface,
it looked like it
was darker anyway.
So some of the dust would
have been blown off.
>> Dr. Scott Guzewich: Right.
So the question, when the rover
landed and kind of looked bluish
on the surface, again,
that's sort of a,
the blue is probably more
of an imaging processing,
but it certainly was darker
because the dust got all blown
away, and so you saw that sort
of native rock color
beneath the layer of dust.
And the dust, you
know, gets in the way
of a lot of the measurements.
So like Sojourner went up to all
these different rocks and had
that little instrument
that kind of sniffed them.
Well you know what
they detected?
Dust. That's what they detected.
Every rock was made of dust,
and so with more knowledge,
so Spirit and Opportunity had
this little tool called a RAT,
Rover Abrasion Tool,
which basically kind
of ground the rock down as
much as possible to get rid
of that dust so they could
actually measure what the rock
is made of.
And then we have, Curiosity has
like a brush that'll
brush the dust off.
The little laser beam on
Curiosity will make a few blasts
to basically clear the
dust off a spot before they
start measuring.
And then of course the
drill can get beneath that.
So we have tools now to
get away from the dust
because the geologists don't
find it as interesting as I do.
Yes?
>> Yeah, so you had indicated
that there is particular
seasons, you know,
cloudy season and what not.
Have you then identified
systems and streams much
like what we have here on Earth,
like the thing that happened
in the Pacific and Atlantic that
indicate those weather patterns.
>> Dr. Scott Guzewich: Right.
So the question is
about weather patterns
and whether they are similar
to what we see on Earth.
And so the answer is
in a lot of ways yes.
So there are storm systems
that for all the world look
like a storm system, you know,
in winter time here, you know,
with sort of a big comma
head and a big sort of front,
you know, kind of
passing down to the south.
So Mars will see things
like that very often.
There are some differences
though.
They're not quite
as chaotic on Mars.
Mars' atmosphere is
much more regular.
It doesn't behave as
chaotically from year to year.
So if you were on Mars
on a given day, you know,
and you went one year later,
particularly if you're
in the first half of the
year where there's not a lot
of dust storms, the weather is
going to be almost identical,
you know, one year to the next.
You know, you're not going
to get a lot of variability.
Like, hey, one year it
was warm on this day,
and next year it
was cold this day.
Like this April has
been chilly, right,
but last year it was warm.
And Mars you're not going to
get that sort of variability.
It's just a much more
regular climate just
because the atmosphere
is so much thinner,
and there is just not the
water around in the atmosphere
to drive those differences.
There's not something like an
ocean that's holding all this
heat but then the atmosphere
can sort of interact
with in complicated ways.
With just the atmosphere there,
and a very thin atmosphere
at that, it's much more driven
just by the daily cycle of heat
from the sun, because the sun
heats the atmosphere during the
day, and at nighttime
all that heat goes away,
and the atmosphere
essentially hits a reset button.
It's like okay, the next
day it's a brand new day,
start again.
And the next day, sun comes up,
dust devils kick up, you know,
clouds might be there
in the morning.
Clouds go away.
Dust devils kick up.
Sun gets turned off, and
the next day is a recycle.
And the only big difference
is in the dust storms.
Sometimes the dust storms
can last for days and days.
And those are sort of the
one, you know, chaotic event
that Mars' atmosphere has.
>> Are those effectively those,
those sand storms, right,
dust storms, that I'm assuming
those are fairly predictable
in that like you can see
when they're occurring
because of some sort of
system that's just going
around the planet or
based on certain events
that happened in previous year.
>> Dr. Scott Guzewich:
So, right.
The question is how
predictable are the dust storms?
And the answer is, we know what
seasons they preferentially
occur at and we know where
they preferentially occur,
but we have no predictive
capability to say, oh,
there's going to be a dust
storm here in two days,
or this small dust
storm is going
to become a much bigger dust
storm, you know, next Wednesday.
There's no predictive
capability,
and people are starting to
look towards that sort of thing
with [inaudible] some modelling,
and people are sort of starting
to get towards that, but there
seems to be some challenges
to that that don't exist
for Earth forecasting.
And a lot of it boils down to we
don't understand why storms form
in certain places or at certain
times in the first place.
And so, and kind of going back
to this gentleman's question,
you know, there's dust
in different places
in different amounts.
So maybe all the conditions
are right at this place,
but there's not much
dust on the surface,
so you just have this sort
of, you know, whatever spin
in the atmosphere occurs, it
doesn't create a dust storm,
but then the same sort of
thing happens over there
where there is a lot
of dust on the ground,
and suddenly you have a
big dust storm kick up.
And that's a level of fidelity
that we don't understand.
>> What's the temperature range
roughly where Curiosity is
and does Curiosity work 24
hours a day, or does it have
to shut down at night?
>> Dr. Scott Guzewich:
So the question is,
what is the daily
temperature range at Curiosity
and does the rover
shut down at night.
So the first question is, the
temperature range is huge.
It can be like 100 degrees
Celsius in a given day.
It'll get down extremely cold
at night-time, down to well
over 100 degrees below
zero Celsius or Fahrenheit,
and then in daytime, it
can get up to freezing,
even to like 65 degrees, like
right at the surface maybe.
But then again when the
sun gets turned off,
I mean the temperature
just drops.
There's nothing there
to hold the heat,
and it'll get extremely cold.
And so because of that, yes, the
rover primarily does not do much
at night, and when it does,
it ends up being a
big burden on power.
So there's only so much
power we have every day,
and that radioactive generator
that we have essentially
trickle charges the battery all
the time.
And so we run the rover off
of the battery, and so we kind
of deplete the, you know,
deplete the battery,
and then we basically tell
the rover to go to sleep,
and the rover's battery
can recharge,
and then we start
doing something,
and the battery goes
down and so forth.
And so at nighttime, if
you want to do anything,
you have to run the
heaters really, really hot.
Because every little,
every little instrument
and movement has
it's own heater,
and all those require power.
So if you want to take pictures
at night-time, or if you want
to take measurements
at night-time,
you need to run heaters, and
those take a ton of power.
And so we typically
don't do much
at night sometimes
but typically not.
>> You mentioned earlier
in the talk that sort
of the atmosphere [inaudible],
and are you seeing any changes
in the atmosphere currently in
your monitoring [inaudible].
>> Dr. Scott Guzewich:
Right, okay.
So the question is, the
atmosphere of Mars has depleted
over time as the
atmosphere was lost to space.
Are we seeing any of that
over the amount of time
that we've been on the surface?
No. So the atmosphere has been
about the same every
time we've measured it.
There's been a little
bit of variation,
but it's all kind
of within the noise.
So, we can measure, so the Maven
mission is measuring how much is
being lost per day essentially,
and it's like a couple
kilograms per day
of atmosphere is
being lost to space,
and so we can measure that,
but you can just sort of do
like a back of the
envelop math on that
and how long would it
take for us to sort
of see any difference, and
it's still just, you know,
millennia sort of thing before
we would see any difference.
Yeah. So actually,
when we first landed,
we thought we maybe saw
some differences between,
because Viking did the
same thing 30 years ago,
and we thought maybe we saw
some differences between Viking
and Curiosity, and now we sort
of think why we know basically
that our measurements
are better.
But so people wondered about
that very thing, but it seems
like the answer is just
measurement differences.
>> So, could the frozen water on
Mars be changed to liquid water?
>> Dr. Scott Guzewich:
Okay, so the question is,
could the frozen water on Mars
be changed to liquid water?
Yes, certainly.
It just needs heat basically,
and there are certainly
particular places
and particular times of year
where the air is warm enough,
and there's enough air pressure,
because that's other key
that people on Earth
don't really realize.
Not only for liquid water
do you need it to be warm,
you need to have
enough air pressure
to support liquid water.
And Mars is right
near this point,
this very interesting point
called the triple point
where it's very close
between the boundary
where water is either
gas, solid, or liquid.
And the main condition,
the average condition
on Mars is very, very
much almost at that point.
And so yes, in certain places
you could have liquid water even
today, and so when the Phoenix
Lander, this was back in 2007,
the Phoenix Lander came down
near the north polar cap,
not at the north polar
cap, but pretty close.
So essentially equivalent to
like the Canadian high arctic.
And it landed there, and there's
ice right below the surface,
and I mean right below,
like within an inch or two
of the surface is
essentially pure ice.
And so because when it's rocket
engines landed it blew off all
that dust and saw this basically
this little tiny skating rink
right beneath the surface.
And so the camera kind of looked
underneath of the Lander to see,
look at that ice, and it saw
all these little droplets
on the landing legs.
There was liquid water droplets
on the landing legs of Phoenix,
and it wasn't because water
was pure and it was, you know,
it was 32 degrees or warmer,
because if you've mixed water
with different types of salt,
you know, just if you imagine
like sea water doesn't
freeze at 32 degrees.
Sea water freezes at like 29
degrees for the most part.
And so Mars' soil has a lot of
salt in it and different types,
and so the salt makes
it able to be liquid
at colder temperatures.
And so this is probably
what happened.
There was little bits of ice got
kicked up, mixed with the salt.
When the Lander hit the ground,
and it landed on the legs,
and it got warm the
next day, and it melted.
And so you had these
little droplets
of water on the surface.
And so if you want the whole
polar cap to melt, yeah,
then you just need a lot
more, you need a lot of heat.
You need a lot more
heat because most places
on the planet are always
going to be either too cold
or not have sufficient air
pressure to have liquid water.
>> And also, might there
be some caves on Mars?
>> Dr. Scott Guzewich:
So the question is,
are there caves on Mars?
Yes. There are certainly
caves on Mars.
They've seen from orbit
signs of like volcanic tubes,
so if you go out like in
California there's these
like volcanic lava tubes where
lava used to flow through--
>> Hawaii has a lot [inaudible].
>> Dr. Scott Guzewich: Hawaii,
Hawaii has these as well.
And you can see these sort
of, a lot of times they'll get
like a little hole in the
top called like a skylight,
and you can kind of
see down that there's,
hey there's probably a
lava tube underneath there.
The moon has them also.
And so they've seen these
from orbit around some
of the volcanos on Mars.
And a lot of other caves on
Earth are obviously formed
by liquid water kind of
flowing through, and so, yeah,
probably there are those
types of caves somewhere.
Of course, we just can't
see them from orbit,
and we haven't been on the
ground near the entrance to one.
And even if there was one,
there was no way we
would drive into it.
[laughter] So, yeah.
>> Stephanie Marcus: So
thank you all for coming.
If you want to talk,
you can come
on down while we're
shutting down.
Thank you so much.
>> Dr. Scott Guzewich: Thanks.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.